[Music]
inequality is one of the big problems of
the United States but it's also a big
problem of the world to start with a
problem for the United States inequality
within the United States everybody knows
by now the numbers that 1% or 0.1% of
the people have 80% of the money in the
United States one might say you know if
you're rich you might say well isn't
that sad but those poor people they're
poor because they are lazy and they're
not trying hard and the American Dream
is rags to riches they're poor because
it's all their fault well a big reason
that they are poor is because they're
getting crummy education because
American support for education has
declined because where you live is tied
to the quality of the school where
you're at and if you get a crummy
education you can end up with a crummy
job and you're going to end up poor in
the United States the correlation
between the income of parents and the
income of their children when they grow
up is higher than in any other country
in the world meaning that if you want to
be rich if you're a child and you want
to be rich the best thing to do is to
get born to be born to rich parents
there's a cruel joke which says if you
are a baby choose your parents carefully
because that's the best predictor of
whether you'll end up rich or not you
can say so what difference does it make
for the rich people if they're all these
unhappy unproductive poor people well in
my lifetime in Los Angeles twice I've
experienced riots in my city of Los
Angeles where the riots broke out in the
center of the city where there were lots
of poor people miserable recognizing
that they didn't have any long-term
prospects and they started rioting and
they burning the started burning
there was concern in rich sessions like
Beverly Hills that the rioters would
spread out of the center of Los Angeles
and start wrecking Beverly Hills so what
are the police doing Beverly Hills the
only thing they could do was to string
up strips of this yellow plastic police
tape across the main boulevards with
signs get rioters keep out well at the
time of the last riots
the right as it happened did not invade
Beverly Hills but you can bet there will
be more if there's inequality continuing
the United States they'll be more riots
and the next time the rioters are going
to behave invade Beverly Hills and they
will be burning and doing other bad
things there and yo strips of plastic
police tape will not keep them out so
what does inequality mean for the United
States is really bad for those Americans
at the lower end of the spectrum but
it's going to be dad and maybe fatally
bad for rich Americans
[Music]